jump over a cliff don't tell your baby
daddy you're with child and whatever you
do don't develop feelings for the next
Empress ooh this can't end well Vikings
Valhalla season 2 is out and in this
video we'll be taking a deep dive into
its ending the real history behind the
show and what it could mean for season
three so strap on in be sure to like And
subscribe because I may not cover all
the shows you're watching but when I do
it's pretty sweet the end of season 2
has brought us to the coast of Pomerania
located on the Baltic Sea bordering
Modern Day Poland and Germany Olaf
heraldson continues his quest in
crushing the Pagan Vikings who have
hidden away in a small town called
yomsburg the only problem is he isn't
exactly sure where this place is but
believes God has a plan and will show
him the way and as luck would have it
his Fleet stumbles upon a ship belonging
to Yonder The exiled but we'll get into
why this coincidental meeting is so
important after the events of season 1
of Freitas Erics daughter flees to
jomsburg fearing for the safety of her
unborn child when she finds out Olaf
survived the battle of catagan and will
stop at nothing to have her killed Swain
forkbeard father of king knut of Denmark
appoints Olaf as protector to his
grandson princess vane while Fort beard
will look after Olaf's own son at Magnus
this exchanges to keep Olaf in line for
if Olaf proves to be insubordinate it
could result in the death of his son
Freitas hasn't told her baby daddy
Harold sigurdson the prince of Norway
that she is with child she fears that
Harold would raise him to be a Christian
I guess I cannot have a child
one day would be the ruler of a
Christian Mission so the two end up
going their separate ways Harold and
Leif Ericsson to Novgorod in search of
an army to take back katigat and Freitas
to yomsburg where she believes she can
peacefully have her child it's in
Johannesburg that Freitas meets Yonder
and his uncle harakar harakar is based
off real historical figure hark of
chiota who led a successful peasant
revolt against Olof Haroldson hadakus
the leader of this small town made up of
many refugees facing Christian
persecution and he asked Freitas if
she'd be the town's Goodyear or
spiritual leader in season one Freitas
traveled to uppsala the holiest site for
the Pagan Vikings and received a special
blade from their Goodyear which she'll
later use in her battle against Olaf
what does it say on your sword it says
The Keeper of the fate uppsala and its
people were butchered by yarrow Carr at
the end of season 1 and now it's up to
Freitas to continue her people's holy
Traditions harakar soon grows jealous of
freitas's growing influence and devises
a plot to kill her asking his nephew
Yonder to poison her food instead you
earned their AIDS in her Escape but is
caught doing so his uncle even puts him
on trial for the death of Freitas even
though she was never found this is how
he ends up lost in the ocean exiled and
later picked up by Olaf this is where
things get interesting Olaf is looking
for yomsburg and you're under knows
where to find it and yorander now has
motive to join forces with Olaf to get
back at his evil uncle but what he
doesn't know is that since he left
Freitas has taken back control of the
town and harakar killed by his own
sister-in-law meanwhile halfway across
the continent how then Leaf are two days
away from their journey to
Constantinople Harold's plea to his
uncle for an army and Novgorod has
fallen on deaf ears and thus he has
taken on a perilous Quest delivering a
mysterious chest to the emperor in
Constantinople in the hopes that the
payment would be enough for him to raise
an army during this journey Leif Eriksen
has fallen in love with Miriam a scholar
who teaches him how to read navigate
using the stars and use mathematics
these are tools he'll undoubtedly use
when traveling to the new world it is
said Leif Erickson is the first person
to land in North America almost a half
Millennium before Christopher Columbus
Miriam however suffers from an unknown
illness which she succumbs to Mere days
before their arrival in Constantinople
before her death she asked him to recite
the song of haval a story about a whale
who emerges from the deep to see the
world for a brief moment before
disappearing back into the deep it's a
metaphor for their relationship it was
brief beautiful while it lasted before
one of them descends back from whence
they came she gives Leaf a key to her
house in Constantinople which we'll see
him hold on to as they make their way to
the city's Port it'll be interesting to
see what Treasures await him that will
help him and Harold on their Journey
next season yorander divulges yomsburg's
weakness the main Sentinel which could
potentially destroy their ships should
they make an attack by sea if they take
out the Sentinel the city will be
defenseless hola off asks for a parlay
bringing along Yonder who finds out
harakur is dead and Freitas has taken
back control unbeknownst to Olaf
yonder's mother gives him a message from
Freitas to lure Olaf's men into the
harbor she gives him back his necklace
which was taken from him after being
exiled a symbol that he is Forgiven
meanwhile in London Queen Emma and Earl
Godwin continue their game of cat and
mouse the queen believes Godwin
complicit in an attempt to assassinate
her even going so far as to torture his
fiancee to death in the hopes of getting
a confession unfortunately for the queen
when her husband King knut arrives back
in town and hears of this situation he
offers Godwin his niece Gita to marry to
make up for this terrible mistake here
is where things get spicy Emma believes
Godwin wanted this all along that he
planned the assassination wanted his
fiancee to die and to be given Gita as a
bride because that would get him one
step closer to his dream fathering
children that would one day become Kings
Gita is a of Royal Blood but his
ex-fiance elf win who died was not this
is why the queen gives Gita a ring
necklace as a wedding present and asks
her to wear it every day this ring
belonged to Godwin's Guardian John the
bear Fletcher but how did such a
valuable ring come into the hands of a
simple farmer it's implied here that
this ring was a gift from Godwin and
Godwin charged the man with hiring the
Assassin and later killed him to cover
his tracks therefore giving the ring to
Gita is the Queen's way of telling
Godwin I know what you've done Godwin's
dream of his son becoming king became a
reality in 1066 when his son Harold
godwinson became king of England only
later to be killed in the Norman
Conquest but for season 3 expect Queen
Emma and Godwin to further butt heads
back at the war council yoranda advises
Olaf not to attack but he believes with
God on his side they are sure to win
they attack the main Sentinel and yondyr
betrays Olaf and his men adjoining sides
with the people but dying in the process
us his last words are to tell his mother
he was not a traitor near Constantinople
Harold and Elena have developed feelings
for one another but Harold is in for one
hell of a shock when he discovers it's
not the treasure necklace he was to
bring to the emperor but Elena herself
she is to Wed the emperor for bringing
her safely to him the emperor grants
Harold anything he wishes so it looks
like he may be getting that Army after
all remember he told his uncle in
episode 3 when I return I will be a rich
and powerful man
my own Army and the purpose what will
undoubtedly get in the way of that is
this budding relationship between him in
the emperor's bride but when he tells
her she's now out of his reach she says
nothing is
and Harold's gotta be like so you're
telling me there's a chance even though
the main Sentinel is still operable the
yoms Vikings allow Olaf's Fleet safe
passage into the harbor this is all part
of freitas's plan she's planted dozens
of jars of oil underneath the harbor
that when opened and said a flame will
completely decimate Olaf's Fleet luckily
Olaf and Prince vayne make it to land
before the attack and The Season's
climax sees Freitas and Olaf in a
one-on-one battle for control of
yomsburg eventually Freitas gets the
upper hand and Olaf is killed believing
he's made himself to be a martyr and his
name will be remembered for all of
eternity but Freitas is like but who is
Left To Tell your story in reality Olaf
was killed in the Battle of sticklestad
in 1030. a year later he'd be named a
saint by the pope for his work in
spreading Christianity a bit ironic
considering that involved killing
thousands of people now Freitas could
have easily killed the Young Prince but
instead travels back to karagat and
offers him to his mother the queen of
Denmark as a peace offering which this
queen accepts this completes freitas's
character Arc this season in episode 1
she did not accept her Destiny as Keeper
of the faith you pray this the keyboards
are Faith aren't you I don't know who
you meant but by the end of the season
she has fully embraced it you arthritis
aren't you
The Keeper of the faith yes
I am Vikings Valhalla season 3 started
filming mid-2022 so expect an early 2024
release for season 3 and although
nothing has been confirmed Beyond season
3 Creator Jeb Stewart says he has plans
to continue the Viking Saga until the
end of the Viking era around 1066 A.D so
there's still a lot more story to tell
but what did you think of Vikings
Valhalla I want to hear your thoughts
and theories in the comments below
thanks for watching be sure to like And
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstory YT until next time remember
so you're telling me there's a chance
foreign